elle a eu la plus grosse fortune de
france sur le départ bernard arnault
président du groupe lvmh aurait demandé
fin août la nationalité belge
ça suffit ces gens sont dépassés top
nature d'une obsession c'est de
démanteler ce centre vous avez quand
même de supprimer
combien milan points vous avez l'air de
lui en vouloir un petit peu en bas âge
sûrs en veut à mort tu es ce que y'a
plein de filles qui sont au chômage à
cause de lui on est des pions votre
envoyé pour nos tpe seydoux maintenant
quand les stars une chance existe plus
et pour l'esprit des maîtresses
terrestre de bernard regarde c'est ça la
preuve
comment vous faites pour vivre être
euros par mois bonjour non moins cher
droits et le respect revault porte
parole
bonjour on aurait voulu monter à l'étagé
des matchs s'il vous plaît alors
approché qu'est-ce qui va chercher à
faire romane est morte et forcé leur âge
étaient là on va les faire les dents
merde détonateur de bernard n'doumi 120
ch et l'image désespoir 1re civ ou de
pays pauvres j'ai fait deux fautes à
paris vous comprenez bien qu'on peut pas
céder à un chantage le gêner au purin à
perte c'est nous qu'on soit les pédales
et bernard les pirates étaient bien les
pdg alors pdg